moist critical is not your average
internet personality he's immature if my
soft pink fell out of my pants in front
of an on-duty police officer he wouldn't
even arrest me he'd feel too bad about
it he's awkward well that's got to be a
world record thanks for the fat 10 gift
Subs Pikachu Mike is throbbing throbbing
what is xqc's chat saying right now he's
completely monotone I'm gonna go ahead
and say this is my real voice I'm not
pretending to make my voice deep and I'm
not using a Darth Vader mic or something
he's not particularly great at games he
wears the same white T-shirt every day
of his life and he's kind of a weirdo I
was an extra in The Hunger Games
Mockingjay part one I know I know no
autographs I'm just a normal person like
all of you I put my pants on one nipple
at a time and wipe my ass crack after a
hardship with both hands and yet he's
one of the most important people on the
internet he's the guy every gamer wants
to be he's living the dream dream and he
did it all by being himself all right
I'm just gonna speedrun YouTube drama
today and just rip this [__] off like a
Band-Aid and get it over with quickly is
hello it is Hollow
I think at this point it's safe to say
Activision Blizzard is the most evil
video game company ever
went for that's what it's all about
oh I got a unicorn fish
[Music]
oh baby
15 years ago on what was probably just
another humid summer day in Tampa 13
year old Charlie White uploaded a short
video to his new YouTube channel
The Man Who Would One Day me known as
moist critical named his channel penguin
zero and for years he mostly uploaded
highlight reels of FPS hijinks and
generic gameplay videos to put it simply
his channel looked like every Small Time
gaming YouTubers there didn't seem to be
anything special about him and yet as
critical turned the new metal down and
started talking to his audience in his
videos his channel started growing hey
what's up everybody it's critical I'm
gonna be showing you all the three best
BioShock 2 loadouts for low levels
medium levels and higher levels he was
just another person amongst thousands
uploading gaming content to YouTube no
one even knew what he looked like so
what made him so special well to start
critical was genuinely hilarious he had
a quick wit the world's most monotoned
voice to suit his deadpan humor and a uh
unique imagination so I'm not
complaining about the spawns but in
reality I could probably run to Area 51
from my house find where they're holding
E.T captive rub my nipples and run back
to my house and still be five seconds
away from spawning now I know most of
you don't like Modern Warfare 2 and
neither do I I personally think this
game sucks through a crazy straw let's
do this you're done
well rub my nipples with sandpaper and
beat my weiner with nitroglycerin
somehow that [__] got me critical was
building a dedicated fan base of people
who loved his weird sense of humor and
he caught the attention of one of the
biggest Youtubers of the time Ray
William Johnson now this video is at
about a hundred thousand views and it's
six minutes long but if you watch the
whole thing it's hilarious because the
guy's humor is so dry Johnson's
recommendation propelled critical into
stardom overnight his views exploded but
that brought him a new problem money
with increased viewership came increased
ad revenue and critical wanted nothing
to do with it as some of you know I'm
not partnered with YouTube or anything
else by my own choosing because I do not
wish to get any money from doing
something I enjoy doing I make videos
entirely for fun so I do it for free by
my own choosing I think money can
corrupt people and I just really enjoy
making videos so I don't want to receive
money from it but just because because
he was giving away the money didn't mean
he stopped growing by 2014 critical hit
1 million subs and while that should
have been an incredible feat it was
tainted by 2015 critical was struggling
to find a job which meant he had to
break his promise and start taking money
earned from his YouTube channel he was
having relationship problems economic
issues and a crisis of Faith a month ago
I made that video about how I've hit
rock bottom and I'm at the lowest point
in my life but I'm trying to be
optimistic because my girlfriend broke
up with me and I just couldn't find a
job still can't find a job I want
everyone to know my name I want my name
to be remembered I want to be remembered
I want to be remembered as someone who
made a positive impact on the entire
world The Only Way Forward was to dive
all the way in to commit to YouTube
wholeheartedly to reveal the real moist
critical what's up everybody it's
critical delivering a really high
enthusiasm into for this very special
video in 2017 10 years after starting
his channel critical uploaded his first
ever video with his face in it he Dove
deep into his issues with self-esteem
OCD and burnout he put his true self in
front of his audience helping further
Revitalize his passion for YouTube he
started uploading new videos almost
every day on just about anything
speedruns of games you've never heard of
reviews more commentary videos and most
importantly reactions to gaming news and
internet drama as the year went on more
and more of his most hardcore fans
realized that hidden underneath
critical's immature ridiculous Persona
was a smart and thoughtful commentator a
guy who approached Gaming's biggest
stories with a level head and a careful
perspective gamers are very entitled and
childish people for the most part I
don't want to say the entire Gaming
Community is but let's be honest for the
most part they are because every time
something negative in a game gets
implemented the same [__] happens these
children send death threats let's make
our voices be heard let them know that
we're not satisfied let's try and ruin
their lives that'll show them and it's
just it's disgusting moist critical kept
growing by 2018 he hit 2 million subs
and mainstream press were starting to
reference him in their coverage of
gaming and YouTube he launched his
twitch Channel and was quickly becoming
one of the biggest names on the internet
and yet people were still asking the
same question how did he do it moist
critical was the anti-youtuber he was
just some dude he didn't really do
thumbnails he didn't get hyped up over
everything he didn't really play the
popular games he didn't even change his
clothes and yet his growth was
Unstoppable simply because he was
himself watching his content is like
hanging out with a digital roommate a
friend who will always say the most
insane thing they can think of make you
cry with laughter and then out of
nowhere say something truly brilliant
two types of men in this world many have
tried to suck their own [__] and liars
and critical wasn't really like any
other streamers the biggest streamers
are often incredible at the games they
play or constantly courting and
generating controversy sometimes both
but critical managed to stay himself and
grow despite not being any of that he
found the way to stay moist while
quickly becoming a part of the circle of
massive twitch streamers many of whom
respected him because they watched him
back in the day I know I've been friends
with Charlie for a while now I forget
when we first chatted I think it might
have been at POG Champs uh and how I
watched him when I was a kid I mean
we're the same age I didn't know this
but uh he was blessed by having a deep
voice and I was cursed with a squeaker
Voice by 2020 moist was making moves on
Twitch he was a part of every meta from
among us to react content to opening
Pokemon cards
yes yes yes yes yes
that's like a twenty thousand dollar
card
his growth was massively accelerated
through being in some of the biggest
Among Us lobbies including playing with
AOC
there we go okay I have no more tasks
that wasn't enough to make him one of
twitch's biggest names he also made
headlines that year by winning POG
Champs the inaugural streamer chess
tournament and provided the world the
greatest chess twitch clip of all time
when he beat xqc in eight moves well
that's gotta be a world record thanks
for the fat 10 gift Subs Pikachu Mike is
throbbing throbbing what is xqc's chat
saying right now moist was on top of the
world five years ago he was saying he
wanted everyone to know his name now he
was a twitch and YouTube Superstar not
only that people listened to him because
he had level-headed takes on the things
that twitch and YouTube fans cared about
most I see gamblings become kind of big
these days
so that's a little dangerous I've never
had a problem with it but uh
uh I see a lot of young people
not here not necessarily here but I was
watching
and it's seems a bit dangerous uh I
think when you see one of your favorite
streamers you get like a huge payday and
you're like an impressionable 15 16 year
old
by 2021 critical started paying it
forward he founded his own Esports team
why well for fun so if Cola does want to
actually take the moist Esports Journey
I'm sure we could probably set him up
with some sponsors to pay him to play
and maybe we can grow moist Esports into
something more real but for now this
really was something started just for
some fun and to help Cola who I think is
a very deserving player get into Summit
and provide him with anything he would
need to compete so that's what it is for
now it's nothing super huge but it is
something that we are pretty passionate
about turning into something kind of big
at some point moist Esports signed Cola
a Smash Bros ultimate player then
hotashi from Guilty Gear strive then
more Smashers an apex team and an entire
rocket League Squad and they popped off
hold on
any other one
[Applause]
oh a dash attack also good trying to
find the KO good grab good grab come on
come on come on
yes yes
let's go
thank you
ladies oh my [__] God yes
bite being one of the biggest names on
the internet moist never lost sight of
where he started he kept fighting for
the little guy and calling out Bad
actors whenever he saw them this is a
video I probably should have made two
years ago but the person it's about is a
parasite who thrives off of attention
and controversy he himself comes forward
and says he only does these things so
people will make videos about him and
while he doesn't donate everything he
earns to charity anymore he's still
doing his best to give back in 2021 he
held pure rare disease's biggest charity
stream ever moist critical went from
absolute rock bottom to the top of the
world and his community recognized him
for that in 2022 he won best variety
streamer at cutie Cinderella's streamer
Awards powered both by fan votes and
nods from his streaming peers but of
course he accepted it in his own special
way oh my God I feel like I just pulled
a PSA 10 first edition Charizard
baseless shadowless well Bel Delphine
was playing with my nipples and and
nikokano avocado was licking my [__]
um I just want to say thank you guys so
much for this I want to thank the Moyes
critical team Charlie Charlie Charlie
and Charlie but for all the ridiculous
nonsense that award did mean a lot to
moist so winning this is super special
to me and it's especially shocking
because I never even mentioned the award
show on stream I never told the
community to go spam votes for me or
anything like that so the fact that I
was able to squeak out a win there is
shocking like genuinely astonishing he's
in a band he's made a comic book he
bought a theme park critical is living
every 14 year old's dream he's still
ridiculous and crude and not for
everyone he still wears the same shirt
every day and has all the vocal energy
of a sleeping grandpa but at the same
time he's one of the most honest giving
and undeniably authentic content
creators out there he's not doing it for
the views or the money he started a
whole Esports team for the same reason
he started uploading videos and
streaming because he thought it would be
fun because he wanted to make every day
as memorable as possible for himself and
anyone else along for the ride
[Music]
holy [__] all right
but he's also a new kind of Internet
content creator he isn't above the drama
but he manages to avoid being drowned in
it he doesn't Crush people at every game
he plays he's just a guy who loves games
and lives the dream he truly is the
greatest something of all time so yeah I
mean that's that's about it see ya
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock
[Music]